à l'époque où nous avions des gagnants, j'avais peur de
te perdre au concours
cinq fois tu as gagné le all-
american c'était il y a longtemps n'était-ce
pas avant l'accident
[Musique]
avant l'alcool
tu sais combien de personnes me l'ont dit  pour juste
te lâcher
tu vas dire n'importe quoi howard
j'ai toujours pensé à toi comme un petit
homme faible et sans tripes
mais tu sais qu'il n'y a aucune raison d'être
impoli
tu me dois mike tu m'as donné ta parole
et cela signifiait quelque chose
mon fils  raphael il a des ennuis je veux le
faire sortir du mexique
nous voulons que j'aille là-bas et que je le kidnappe
s'il vous plaît ramenez le juste ici
juste toi juste moi
[Musique]
ici après que tu sois sorti maintenant
je suis un ami de la famille
touche-moi et donne un coup de pied à ton mec jésus
christ  être fort
naturel
j'étais beaucoup de choses
mais je ne le suis plus maintenant
[Musique]
je vais te  ll vous quelque chose
cette chose macho est surestimée
juste les gens qui essaient d'être macho montrent
qu'ils ont du courage
c'est à peu près tout ce qu'ils finissent avec
c'est comme n'importe quoi d'autre dans la vie vous
pensez que vous avez toutes les réponses
[Musique]
et vous réalisez  en vieillissant tu
n'en as aucun
nous devons tous faire des choix dans la vie gamin
tu dois faire le tien
carte macho
c'est bon pour moi
toi